No.
The thing about monetary policy is just
to get to your question about why asset
prices,
where the place where some of the
stresses took place,
you never know exactly where the impact
will take place.
Sometimes it's in broad measures of
inflation,
sometimes it's certain sectors.
First Energy has been a commonplace.
We're price pressures first build up.
In this case,
a lot of them were in the housing market
and I think that was because we already
had beginning of,
uh,
of uh,
housing,
uh,
boom going.
And so in a sense,
what the low interest rates did was
accelerate that.
Plus of course with the adjustable rate
mortgages around and available,
they'll very low interest rates enabled
there to be more teaser rates,
more very low starting rates.
And so that added to the housing boom
itself.
As you know,
during this period there was a big
increase in the fraction of mortgages
that came through the adjustable rate.
And so those,
those extra low interest rates affect
the things there.
But you also had a general increase in
inflation during this period.
It was creeping up,
uh,
each year,
2000 to 2003,
2004 2005 and the and the acceleration
of the housing boom was on top of that.
I think the distinction between price
level targeting and inflation targeting,
which has had a huge amount of attention
in the academic literature and has been
referred to in the past such as Ben
Bernanki before he became chairman.
I think those distinctions in practice
get blurred by the realities quite
frankly.
It of course would be good to have a
price level targeting other things equal
that would sometimes require deflation.
However,
and a lot of evidence is that that's not
such a good thing to have even
occasionally,
so I've always been of the view that
inflation target and it makes more
sense.
It's easier for people to understand.
We've had a lot of practice with it.
And while there is this problem of if
you like of of a drift to drift of the
price level sometimes called base drift
overall it seems to me if we were able
to keep the inflation rate at a very low
level,
then we would effectively get similar
results to price level targeting.
I think the Fed cut interest rates,
um,
they're in that period just about a
right.
I think it was basically coming down to,
could have been a little faster at that
point.
And of course GDP did a fall
tremendously.
But I think if they had kept the
interest rates,
uh,
along the same path,
it would have been fine.
The problems I see at that period was
the tremendous amount of uncertainty
added,
uh,
by these,
these new effects.
If he liked the quantitative easing.
And sometimes I've called somewhat
pejoratively my industrial policy where
the action's went well beyond the usual
interest rates.
And I don't think they were appropriate.
We're still studying them.
Some of them were inappropriate.
I just finished a study on mortgage
interest rates.
So,
so the question about whether policy
could have been even easier going into
the panic.
Uh,
it is certainly something to examine,
but I think basically it's about all it
could do at that point.
The,
the problems I saw were not so much in
monetary policy at that stage,
but they really,
uh,
ad hoc,
um,
chaotic,
uh,
interventions that occurred around the
time of the roll out of the tarp.
Um,
Eh,
not clear kind of actions with respect
to what happened with Lehman brothers.
So there's a lot of surprises and
ultimately a lot of panic.
And I think that panic was induced as
I've argued in other places by
government actions.
I think some of the actions of the Fed
after the panic began were constructive
to be sure,
but I don't see that in terms of a
faster or reductions in just rates.
In fact,
if I could just add,
one thing that I think people should
recognize is that while the federal
funds rate target of the FLMC came down
gradually in the fall of 2008,
the actual rate came down quite a bit
more rapidly.
In fact,
each of the FMC decisions effectively
ratified the,
what the rate was already at and that
rate came down so rapidly because of the
large expansion in reserve.
So it's hard to see how measured in
terms of interest rates policy could
have been much easier in the October,
November,
December period.
Well,
I was under the CBO advisory board for
several years,
so I have thought a lot about that
question about how accurate the CBO
projections are over time.
I think they do a reasonable job.
They of course focus first on what's
happening with the labor force on those,
those groves that are relatively easy to
forecast that because you know what the
population is going to be,
the more difficult part of course is
projecting productivity and uh,
that's uh,
that's effectively a crap shoot.
It's very hard to project it accurately.
I think they do as good a job as anyone,
but you also have to realize that any
longterm projection like that is subject
to a tremendous of ans uncertainty.
I think basically the will you have to
do is take that uncertainty into
account.
Now,
the CBO course projects much more than
10 years.
They're projecting out many decades in
order to get estimates of the cost of
the unfunded liabilities.
Those are even more uncertain.
Frequently there,
there are too optimistic I think after
watch for that.
But I wouldn't have a general complaint
about longterm CBO.
It seems to me to doing about as best as
you can and they're really not
challenged much in one direction.
Either way,
things California should do to fix it.
Its economy.
I think first you've got to recognize
California has enormous potential.
It has a,
it's a great environment.
Uh,
it's very open to new ideas.
Silicon Valley,
it's got great universities,
great.
Um,
both the University of California in the
private universities.
So the potential is tremendous.
What we really need to do in California,
here's the deal with the serious,
a budget problem,
which means spending grows too much and
then taxes rise and that tends to drive
out businesses and ultimately is harmful
to the state.
So I would say number one in terms of
the question is,
is put some a limit on the growth of
spending population growth.
Plus inflation is one way to do it,
uh,
that would prevent the ups and downs and
the,
and the deficits spending usually rises
rapidly when tax revenues rob and then
tax revenues fall off and you got this
huge deficits.
So control the growth of spending number
one.
Number two,
it put in some tax reforms that prevent
the ups and downs in revenues to be so
great.
And here we've got a huge cyclical,
uh,
performance in tax revenues.
So I would adopt some of the proposals
of the recent California Tax Commission
that a governor Schwarzenegger,
I introduced and third edge,
uh,
education K12 it's slipping in
California.
I think it's not a matter of of spending
a lot of spent in California.
It's really demanding more
accountability.
I'd like to see a program where there is
more for teachers and less for
administration on,
I think that would do a lot of good.
No,
I don't think they should target bubbles
like that.
The impacts of monetary policy occur
with a long variable lags as Milton
Friedman showed many years ago and seen
a lot of evidence.
So timing to deal with bubbles is leaves
a lot to be desired,
but more important.
I don't think that has been the problem
with respect to monetary policy.
Certainly not in this serious crisis.
I think having interest rates too low
for too long.
And the 2002,
three,
four period,
uh,
was really effectively inducing a lot of
the,
the bubbles and asset prices,
especially housing.
So if interest rates were higher,
closer to what they would have been
under the policy followed,
and most of the eighties and nineties,
then I think we wouldn't have had nearly
as much of a booming and bus problem.
Not as much of a bubble as we had.
So,
so until policy can stop preventing
bubbles,
it seems to me that's the number one
priority and the,
that people think there's somehow
possible to bust them.
It seems to me that is not really
feasible.
And let's get back to the policies of
really most of the eighties and nineties
that were,
was working without serious bubbles.
The bubble problem,
the housing problem in this crisis
occurred primarily because of a policy
getting off track.
Let's get it on track first and then
worry about,
uh,
about the bubbles.
I think the bubbles will be much less of
a problem.
They're not going to disappear,
of course,
but much less of a problem if Monterey
policy followed the kind of actions we
had,
uh,
through much of the eighties and
nineties.
Well,
the question is,
given that the Taylor rule has large
negative interest rates right now,
would I want more quantitative easing?
Well,
first of all,
I don't think the Taylor rule does show
large negative interest rates right now.
That's kind of a myth.
Taylor rules,
you know,
pretty simple.
It just says the interest rate should
equal one and a half times the inflation
rate plus a half times the GDP gap plus
one.
Well,
if you plug in reasonable estimates for
what inflation is and what the GDP gap
is,
I get a number,
it's pretty close to zero,
not minus four,
minus five,
not numbers like that.
So,
so in fact I would say the amount of
quantitative easing,
uh,
it could be reduced.
Um,
right now I hope,
I hope it is reduced in a gradual way.
Some of the mortgage purchases I think
can be slowed down and then actually
reversed.
So a,
it's a,
it's a question is a good one and I'm
glad it was asked because there is a lot
I think of misinformation out there
about what the Taylor rule says that
Taylor was a very simple,
as I just mentioned,
you can say it,
uh,
in,
in a sentence and you plug in the
numbers,
you don't get minus five minus 6%,
you get something much closer to,
to zero where the interest rate is now.
Now that of course has implications
going down the road because it says to
the extent that real gd pick picks up,
I hope it does,
uh,
or if inflation picks up,
hope it doesn't.
But if either of those occur,
then you'd have to see interest rates
starting to move above this zero to 25
basis point range.
And if we don't,
then we're going to be back into the
same kind of situation we were in 2002
through four and that of course could
begin to induce bubbles.
And we certainly don't want that to
happen.
No,
I don't think quantitative easing at
this point,
uh,
would,
effectively smooth the recovery.
I think right now,
based on historical experience,
the interest rate is about where it is.
It's not that we don't need a lot of
quantitative easing.
We've had some,
I think the job of the Fed now is to
bring it back.
They're talking about doing that,
which is good.
So I think for me the most important
thing now for policy to have a good
recovery is to reduce this tremendous
amount of uncertainty that exists with
re boat for both monetary policy and
fiscal policy.
And the uncertainty for monetary policy
is we don't know how rapidly the
quantitative easing will be reversed.
We don't know what's going to happen
with interest rates or is a lot of
questions there.
So I'd say get back to the things that
were working during the great moderation
period,
the eighties and nineties primarily.
And that means letting interest rates
rise appropriately and reducing the
amount of quantitative easing.
Getting back to where it was a through
most of the policy in the eighties and
nineties.
I think the most important unresolved
question and monetary economics is the
interaction between the financial sector
and uh,
monetary policy,
uh,
has been lots of thinking about it over
the years.
Some of it actually done here at
Stanford,
girly and Shaw,
a lot of it done by tobin at Yale.
Uh,
uh,
Ben Bernanki has done some good,
but I think the most promising part is
the combination of the newest work on a
pricing of,
of uh,
bonds and securities.
A lot of it's done by Monica PSAC and
some of her colleagues to combine that
with,
uh,
with monetary policy so that you have a
sense of what's going to happen to
longer term rates when the short rate is
reduced.
What's going to happen to credit flows
and how much are credited flow is going
to impact the economy.
Uh,
this crisis has been very clear in
demonstrating that more work on the
connection between,
I feel like financial economics and,
and monetary policy is needed.
In fact,
there's still a lot of questions out
there and policy about whether the
financial markets performed well or not.
It seems to me,
uh,
if you look at them,
they,
they absorbed a tremendous shock of,
from policies as effectively of a panic,
uh,
induced by some,
some ad hoc policy changes and they
responded quickly,
uh,
and they responded in a way which has
been smooth as the markets themselves,
the institutions,
the financial institutions of course,
uh,
have been great difficulty.
But the markets themselves have worked
well.
So,
so to me though,
the where are we should focus our
attention really is this,
is this connection between the,
the financial markets including the
financial institutions,
uh,
and the monetary policy itself.
I think we need to have both
independence and accountability.
They go together.
That's not one or the other.
So in answer to the question,
how important is fed independence?
I say it's very important,
but a needs to be matched with
accountability.
A lot of the concerns that you're seeing
in the congress,
in the country about the Fed,
the Ron Paul Bill,
I think that's a reaction to what it
looks like.
A very uh,
interventionists actions by the Federal
Reserve.
Not a lot of descriptions of how it
actually occurred is no,
no reports on what's called the section
13 three intervention,
section 13 three,
the Federal Reserve Act,
uh,
which,
which allows for such actions,
but there's very little reporting on how
it actually took place.
So I think the best thing the Fed can do
to get back some of its independence,
and quite frankly,
I think it's lost a little bit in this
crisis.
Best thing it can do is to be very
accountable about some of the
intervention ventures in section 13
three.
That's where most of the transparency
concerns exist at this point.
And then of course to emphasize that
the,
the policy that has worked most well was
the policy of,
of the eighties and nineties.
And when we got off track of the on
that,
uh,
things deteriorated I think did some
recognition of interest rates being so
low for so long and o two o four period,
uh,
by the leadership,
would be very important.
It's discussed in the Fed system is
disgusted by their central banks.
It's discussed quite widely,
but so some recognition of that seems to
me it would be important in terms of
bringing back some of the independence,
the,
the Fed lost.
So I think in independence,
just to summarize Israeli really
important,
it's a essentially we've seen evidence
over time about how it is,
but it has to be matched with a strong
sense of accountability to the Congress,
to the American people for what the Fed
is actually doing.
And See,
I think it's not the thing the Federal
Reserve should be doing.
I think the Fed should be focusing on
the overall level of interest rates,
not trying to intervene in certain
sectors.
I a year ago I wrote a paper and
presented at the annual meetings of the
economists arguing that this was what I
called [inaudible] industrial policy.
It's using monetary policy to intervene
in certain sectors.
Certain firms is of course part of that
as well.
So I think it'd be better if monetary
policy did not do that.
I've just completed a study trying to
look at the impacts of the purchases of
the mortgage back securities by the Fed
and I,
I actually don't think there is large
had as large an impact on rates to as
many people believe.
We'll be studying that for a while,
but more important the impact is quite
unreliable.
It's a very hard to measure a lot of
uncertainty.
So the notion that the Fed could go in
the business of,
of controlling the mortgage rates as it
has affected the funds rate for years I
think is really a mistaken wishful
thinking.
It would take the Fed in the wrong
direction.
So this is the more we can get back to a
monetary policy which is focusing on the
overall level of the money supply of the
overall level of interest rates rather
than intervene in certain sectors the
better.
That's not monetary policy.
That's the kind of things that raise
peoples doubts about monetary policy.
They question,
why should an independent agency of
government be intervening in certain
sectors like that?
Uh,
the,
the Treasury has bought a mortgage,
mortgage back securities that doesn't
raise the same independence questions,
uh,
that the Fed has raised by these
purchases.
So it's,
it's one of the biggest issues now,
uh,
to address,
if you read,
for example,
Brian's sacs recent speech,
he's a at the New York Fed,
he acts as if this is like a new
instrument for monetary policy in the
future.
Uh,
one of his predecessors,
Peter Fisher,
who's now at Black Rock,
uh,
cause this price keeping operations.
And I think there's a huge amount of
doubts about this a,
its effectiveness,
its reliability,
and it has,
uh,
raises questions about the Fed's
independence.
So I feel strongly that this is not the
kind of thing that we should have the
Fed doing in the future.
No,
I don't think there's any reason to do
that.
I always assumed the inflation target
should be 2%.
If some people think it should be lower,
let's maybe talk about changing it,
but varying across the business cycle
seems to me to be just an extra element
of confusion.
Uh,
two people,
there's no reason to do that.
So the question is for me,
his mood,
how would you adjust it?
I think rather than move it around in
the business cycle,
is to do as good a job as possible as
assessing what,
how you measure the inflation target.
There was a been a lot of confusion,
for example,
about using the core inflation rate.
I've always preferred to use a smoothing
device.
That is the average inflation rate over
a few quarters is actually a four
quarters in the Taylor rule.
But the core rates,
uh,
especially if they're consistently
higher than the headline rates over
several years,
then uh,
or lower would be the other way around.
Then they can be misleading.
So for one year or so,
paying attention to the core and looking
at that's important,
but,
but ultimately it's the,
it's the measured inflation rate,
the headline inflation rate that's most
important.
And that's what I would focus on.
And again,
no reason to be changing that that would
just add confusion and uncertainty to
what monetary policy is doing.
I think of these as the original cause
of he like really what got the excess is
going.
It was a big deviation,
300 basis points.
Um,
we hadn't seen deviations like that
since 19 seven days,
which of course was another period of
uh,
lots of recession's a very severe one
and I'm 81,
82.
Uh,
so I think that there is a,
a lot of evidence that says this was a
really the factor that got things going
in terms of the excess is the boom and
ultimately the bus and housing,
the,
the search for a yield,
the extra risk taking.
Uh,
and I think you could have a guests that
something would happen based on a
previous periods where central banks
have deviated from the Taylor rule or
other similar guidelines.
It's,
it's amazing to me through history and
through time how much evidence there is
that when central banks deviate from
that kind of policy that things don't
work out well.
And we saw that and the United States in
the seven days,
terrible time with high inflation and
recessions.
We've seen it in other countries.
And as countries started to follow those
principles,
things got better.
And so in some sense,
we now unfortunately have another piece
of evidence that when policy deviated,
uh,
we had a big recession.
I actually say the great moderation was
ended by the great deviation,
which has led to this great recession.
Now I want to be very clear that other
things happened that made this situation
worse.
I made that clear.
And,
and,
uh,
my book,
for example,
getting off track,
that there was really three things,
the deviation from a monetary policy
rules.
The second was misdiagnosing the crisis
in the summer of 2007 as a liquidity
problem rather than a problem in the
banks.
And the third was this,
this panic in the fall of 2008,
September,
October,
which I think was largely a result of
the rather chaotic,
uh,
government,
responses to the crisis.
So,
so the deviation was part of it,
but they're,
in some sense,
there are other deviations from
policies.
A deviations in the directions of a very
interventionist policies,
misdiagnoses,
which is really why this one has been so
severe.
Unfortunately.
Uh,
Charles Good.
Our has it makes a good point with that,
that the policy responses actually
affect individual behavior.
I think it's a what makes policy
difficult.
I think you can take account of those
and be wary of them and still have
conducted policy.
So I'll give an example.
I think,
uh,
when,
when bond traders,
people in the markets have a sense of
what monetary policy is going to be
liked and they will price securities,
longer insecurities,
medium rums,
securities,
uh,
based on that,
if the policy moves to something else,
say for example,
a deviates from what hadn't been
working,
they,
it takes them a while to figure out
what's going to happen.
But they will adjust the,
adjust their forecast,
their procedures,
their rules of thumb,
sometimes indirectly,
sometimes somewhat in inadvertently
they'll do it.
Uh,
so that's the adjustment.
But that's why we like our policies to
be as predictable as possible.
Uh,
so that people can make these
adjustments.
So I would say this is,
to me goodhart's law is another reason
not to be a changing from a policy
that's worked well.
I'd say not to do too much fine tuning
in a way.
What,
what Goodhart's law shows you is that
efforts to,
to find tune can actually um,
be uh,
something that's it's harmful.
In fact,
I think the period in the early say 2002
for a period,
uh,
that could very well be explained by an
effort to make policy even better than
it was during the great moderation.
If you like trying to find tune in an
extra way,
bring rates below what had worked
before,
those are all fine tuning things.
And,
and I think what messages such as
Goodhart's law show you is that the
reaction to those can sometimes be hard
to predict.
People will begin to see that there's
an,
there's another target does another
idea.
You're moving away from the equilibrium
and,
and that's a reason I think to keep it
simple if you like,
keep the policy as simple as possible.
Keep the regulations as simple as
possible.
And that's true of both monetary policy.
And fiscal policy.
Oh,
there's several ways policy could have
been more predictable in this crisis.
I think first of all,
by sticking to the predictable policy
that worked well in the eighties and
nineties with respect to the setting of
interest rates,
that's something that I think we have a
lot of,
a lot of evidence for.
The was unpredictable,
a surprise if he liked to take rates too
low for so long,
even though there was an effort to
explain it.
Uh,
it was,
it was hard for people to understand how
long that was going to be.
Was it a new policy of actual low
interest rates or not?
So that's an element of unpredictability
that I think has caused damage.
I think a second thing I would stress is
the response to the problems in the
financial institutions.
You know,
first of all,
misdiagnosing it as a a liquidity
problem.
So more liquidity was pumped into the
economy,
new facilities were set up that added
unpredictability rather than looking at
the,
at the evidence that there was a problem
in the banks due to the mortgages and
the,
the other toxic assets.
And then I'd say the third element of
unpredictability,
it's probably the most important for the
severe panic.
And I would go back to,
for example,
the bear stearns intervention.
Let's just take as a given,
although it's debatable that that,
uh,
was the right thing to do and the heat
of the moment very difficult under
pressure.
I've been in policy making jobs.
They know what that's like.
So the decision was to,
uh,
intervene and bail out of bear stearns
creditors.
It seems to me at that that was the
moment to be as clear as possible about
what would be the policy in case another
institution had some problems to
articulate it,
but it was very little description of
it.
In fact,
policies tended to vary from case to
case.
You had the Indian Mac at Wamu,
you had,
of course,
the Lehman brothers,
aig,
Fannie and Freddie.
In each case,
there was a difference in each one.
Seemed to be approached independently,
if you like,
ad hoc without an overall strategy,
that's probably the biggest degree of an
unpredictability.
Equity Holders,
um,
preferred equity holders,
uh,
debt holders,
bank holding company versus bank.
Uh,
various kinds of senior creditors,
counterparties,
huge amount of uncertainty about how
they were going to be treated.
And,
and,
and of course,
when all the ultimate,
uh,
policy was put forth,
the so called a tarp,
uh,
was put forth in a way which was quite
confusing.
The treasury secretary just had a two
and a half pages,
uh,
testified with the chairman of the Fed
and the Banking Committee and,
uh,
couldn't answer in my view,
the questions very well.
Huge,
irate response from,
from the congress at that point.
And it really then became very clear,
I think,
that there wasn't really a policy.
They had not been thinking about it,
at least as evidenced from the testimony
and the other actions.
And so that was probably the most
unpredictable,
most damaging part of this whole
episode.
This is a question about the timing of
the panic and whether it was associated
with the Lehman brothers bankruptcy or
with the responses of the government
more generally.
And basically as soon as that occurred,
I looked at the data and I saw much more
evidence that the panic and the markets
were associated with the government's
responses or a week or 10 days later.
That's the time that say the s and p 500
fell by a nearly 30%,
very a 10 times greater than what
happened.
Um,
at the time of Lehman.
Yes.
And p 500 was higher the Friday after
the Lehman bankruptcy than the Friday
before.
So the,
the,
and there's lots of other data to look
at that shows you that there's as much
more investigation.
Uh,
there's a,
for example,
not one counterparty,
uh,
driven of counterparty to Lehman filed
for bankruptcy after the Lehman case.
There was,
um,
the major creditors we did not fail.
So it's hard to find a direct knock on
effects from that in the data.
So the more I look at it,
the more it seems to me there.
The other explanation,
uh,
makes sense.
Now I'd say now you need to think about
what the counterfactual would have been.
And I guess I'd go back to something
I've stressed before,
that if there had been a clear policy
put forth whereby people could have
expected the possibility at least of a,
a leman being put through bankruptcy,
then there could have been some
preparation.
Uh,
there wasn't any,
the day of the announcement,
um,
in September of 2008,
uh,
people were just beginning to think
about how it work.
It was really,
I think,
a surprise that had been no preparation.
And so it was a jolt.
Let's be sure it was a jolt.
But,
but it seems to me that the direct
connections that people talk about with
the expected cascading and domino
effects,
uh,
we're not there and it really occurs
later.
There's,
there's more evidence for this.
Um,
uh,
John Cochran,
Luigi Zingales in Chicago have have put
more out,
I think the former FDAC chair,
uh,
Bill Isaac has studied it and comes to
the same kind of conclusion.
So while,
well it was originally controversial
when I put this idea of forth over a
year ago actually in a,
in a speech at the,
uh,
Bank of Canada in November of 2008.
Uh,
it was viewed as controversial,
but I just looking at the data then,
but more and more you look at what
happened internally,
talk to people and study,
uh,
the aftermath it seems to me there is at
least as much,
let me just put it evenly at least as
much evidence that uh,
the panic was caused by the response as
distinct from that particular event at
Lehman Brothers.
And I think it's more evidence.
I think it's actually becoming
overwhelming and looking at the data
carefully at um,
spreads in the markets at what's
happening to the equity markets and also
looking at what's happened in the
aftermath of the bankruptcy of Lehman
brothers.
Those are the kinds of,
he like nitty gritty details that we
need to be studying to understand what
happened.
We're doing that work here at Stanford,
at the Hoover Institution,
a lot of focus on,
and we have a whole working group.
It's delving until we're talking.
We've talked to people,
former policy makers,
and also people in the private sector to
try to understand this and match it up
with the data.
And I think that's the most important
thing to do.
Now come to some conclusion about what
actually happened so that we can then
take the appropriate remedies reforms to
make sure it doesn't happen again.
Why have I disapproved of the stimulus
of the,
the like large countercyclical a
Keynesian policies?
Because I don't think we have ever had
much evidence that they work.
And so let me draw it to be specific.
The first stimulus was in early 2008 and
that was largely in the form of one time
rebate check sent to individuals.
A lot of money went out and,
uh,
eat basic economic theory would tell you
that that would not jumpstart
consumption.
People would save most of that.
So unlike what was advertised,
a,
it shouldn't stimulate the economy.
And in fact,
if you go back and look at it carefully,
look at the numbers as I've done,
you don't see an impact.
You see that big rebate just Wen to
people's pockets and didn't,
didn't dot John Stark consumption.
In fact,
consumption's going the other way at
that point.
And then you had the stimulus of a 2009
to the extent that that was based on
sending checks to people,
you see exactly the same thing happening
one time payments,
uh,
temporary,
tax cuts don't stimulate,
uh,
spending or consumption.
And again,
we knew that for years and years and
years,
that's why policy and most of the
eighties and nineties didn't take those
kinds of approaches.
And so,
so then that brings you to the question
about government purchases.
Can that be more effective?
Well,
yes,
in principle it can be if it's timed
right,
if it's a,
if it's done in time,
but this stimulus package of 2008,
the government purchases part of it is
spread out over a long period of time.
Most of them haven't even come in line
yet.
The government purchases side.
And so I don't see that that's a
stimulating the economy.
The rebound in the economy has been to
do to things like inventory changes,
recognition that the panic is over,
uh,
and investment side.
And so,
so you can find the impacts of it.
And it's,
it's unfortunate because that means that
we've got a huge increase in our debt,
uh,
and,
that's ultimately harmful.
We didn't get much out of it in terms of
stimulus.
So I'm,
I'm convinced,
you know,
what I like to do is not just look at
the models.
Uh,
I've looked at a new keynesian model,
looked at a model I built many years
ago,
looked at other people's models,
and they're good for assessing impacts.
But ultimately what we need to do now
that we've had these packages is to look
at what happened.
You go away from the models,
look at what happened.
Did Jumpstart,
did consumption get jumpstarted?
I say no.
Was the recovery due to the stimulus?
It seems not because it was in the form
of investment.
Uh,
so,
so I think ultimately we can learn from
this experience.
I don't know exactly why we moved away
from the policies that we're working,
which is really an aversion to these
large countercyclical policies.
It began in the early 2008 and I just
continued and it may continue further.
And I think let's start learning from
what,
and not be ideological about this,
not consider what school is one in,
but looked at the facts.
And when I look at the facts,
I don't see much impact of these
policies.
I would say the responsibility of Wall
Street in this crisis and it still
hasn't been resolved,
is the dependence on the financial
institutions,
uh,
on the government for a bailout and
interventions.
In other words,
the institutions had become large enough
that,
um,
and complicated enough that at least
that led people to say we needed to have
these,
um,
these bailouts,
these interventions.
Each time it was,
uh,
eh,
people said to be systemic risk.
It was like,
you know,
calling saying there's a fire in a
theater crying fire in a theater.
And it led to these responses,
which I say we're quite chaotic and,
and not,
not systematic.
They really led to problems.
So I think what has to happen in the
future as Wall Street,
the large firms have to find a way to
say,
you know,
we are not going to depend on the
government for bail out,
just like a startup firm out here in
Silicon Valley.
If it fails,
it's not going to be bailed out by the
government.
Same should be true for the large
financial institutions.
They should find a way to do that.
It seems to me some sense they're
responsible for doing that.
They want to be responsible citizens.
But I think in the meantime,
government needs to find a way for it to
get out of this a bailout business.
There's an example.
I would,
uh,
point to where this,
there has been a change in the 1990s.
The IMF,
uh,
did a lot of bailouts.
Uh,
United States participated in some of
those and pays a Mexico,
but it got quite chaotic.
And the case of US Southeast Asia
crisis,
they were sometimes and sometimes not
in,
in the case of Russia,
they were in for a while and they pulled
out.
And of course we had a lot of contagent
and a globally,
but it wasn't until maybe 2002,
three,
that a,
the policy became more predictable and
more understandable.
The IMF,
uh,
let out some procedures that are called
it,
the exceptional access framework and
clarified what their operations would
be.
And so the expectation of a,
of a bailout out of a country,
in this case,
sovereign debt was reduced
substantially.
And I think you saw a huge improvement
in the emerging markets.
Some of them made an extra effort to
build up their reserve.
Some of them they do.
So their deficits,
they made the adjustments and,
and they'd been stronger as a result.
Uh,
and that shows you what can happen if
the policy of a,
it becomes more predictable and less,
uh,
expected bailouts or in the system.